hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Mario Kart with even
plug my channel in we're back with more
battle we did one over on his channel
[Laughter]
[Music]
then you go down and then your stomach
comes up to throw it may turn human then
die it is like I'm sorry we just watch
Hot Fuzz last day how much more do you
have to watch before I accept you much
more few drama isn't like as much of a
necessity Oh like there's there certain
shows and everything that are absolute
most like Hot Fuzz is a must you have to
see that it's so you know like
interesting FAQ
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know every videos chance to make a
difference in someone's life bring this
video up when they meet us in person
really when I open YouTube and you just
you know people say you don't always
know what you want to be showing cuz you
knows every video is someone's favorite
video yeah every video weird even fast
eh see have you ever seen yeah
I was literally made that video to be
like how embarrassing can I make a video
people still defend video yeah you
should I love peeing yeah
dude no it's great people been telling
me to delete pain what the live reaction
to peen
I didn't even own up to it at first it
was the pressure of being like I have to
come up with something great yeah I'm
gonna bide time by making something
stupid in the meantime it's like those
stupid things I think I need to do that
again because I haven't made a stupid
video like that and really funny anyways
links are in the description for these
words because if you wanna see one more
dragon no we are did dress.we King King
you know what video I have no idea why
did so well sort the court yeah I had no
idea why that video did so wait how many
views is that it goes like this
multi-million like the first video
coming three or four in the second video
get like similar I've no idea it did
crazy well and I really didn't know why
and I was trying to like dis ected I was
I was playing the game on my own like
why why is it so popular with people and
like maybe you guys in the comments can
like explain like that video just went
crazy good it wasn't even a compelling
thumbnail it was like just a piece of
the game like an end like the story was
interesting but the gameplay was slow I
was like it's weird when like videos do
really well that you don't expect to do
well like video on my channel I played
you played this recently the world's
easiest game yeah that video did really
well in my channel I don't know why well
what's the even weirder is it does well
but the like ratio and the like numbers
are similar to every other this is what
you did think about like we think about
like what the numbers mean and there's
no answer like matpat like nature may
seem like he knows what he's talking
about but half the time it's all guessed
because we don't have any comic
communication with YouTube so what
everything literally literally none no
communication I got my my hundred
thousand subscriber plaques stolen yeah
and I get like I can't get it back yeah
just like I can't get in contact with
YouTube for them to send me a new one
it's so sad too because it's like
obviously even I I can't get that done
like I am one of the biggest channels on
YouTube I can't just go like hey get him
is that video because we were talking
about like how the video does really
well on views but the likes are pretty
normal
yeah that video fun day in the sand
which is me digging the sand saying I'm
digging yourself a grave that that video
that video has a hundred just over 100k
but it has 20,000 likes yeah which is
like really good yeah for a video with
100k yeah I mean it's just like the
there's so many videos out there that
it's like what like I've asked myself is
like what makes a good video like
nothing really makes it because the
appeal of YouTube and I think people's
mistake is that the the videos that just
seem like genuine things are the videos
that always will do better do ya cuz
like it feels more like just hey my
friend made this cool video yeah yeah
yeah and that's what's really like
that's what I love about doing those
stupid pcs that's what makes it
important that's what makes it special
[Laughter]
hey dude and sometimes I follow it
sometimes I can yes and other times
legislate weird how did your brain
that's a really fun game that I like to
play his talking don't think it's a
dangerous oh god yeah but it's fun I
mean it's good just because it's it
helps your mind okay if you've been
following
series across both of our channels go in
that I don't know why I did better that
time last place oh yeah I got first
every other done though still hasn't
matter anyway so there's been fun they
even for joining me hey thanks links in
the description for peen fast at exe and
his video that we did but I know you're
gonna watch the other ones first thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always we'll see you
[Music]